je vous promets comme d'habitude on est
à refaire l'agent 15la avons à l'antenne
dans combien de temps
ah bon c'est cette voix cette voix
jacques cycle y est oui dit quelque
chose
eh bien j'ai écrit un livre sur averti
dès l'origine à nos clients à verser
larry bord dont le mans paris bordeaux
le monde paris si le test jardot le mans
paris bordeaux le mans a rich aurilia
l'originalité tu vas là je comprends
pourquoi que j'ai pas été élu avec
l'ennemi longo c'est du déjà aussi plate
que j'ai pas ma carte du parti je suis
pas chiraquien pas pourquoi je serais
goncourt quoique il faut être chiraquien
hougard dévoilera de garder vous à
gauche et concours sont prudents avec
moi c'était foutu
ah oui au fait qu'ils m'aident la
prochaine fois bonjour pour ce biseau
est née cette voie non mais ne vous dit
quelque chose
malheureux alors je pense aux bizots
bonjour mais non mais dis parlais ils me
racontent palau à noël ou au nouvel
alphabet a pris jeudi à luz à deux avec
martin a deux trois quais de saint côme
entendez on recevait à la sauce orangina
national jean michel royer le pied le
pied le pied le bilan d'ici là tout à
l'heure mais mesnil jacques pourquoi tu
pourrais tapas offerts dans mineurs
démission à jean christophe averty dans
ton dimanche qui sinon je lui offre tout
la journée ici il veut mars en direct et
indirect que les méchants c'est pas du
direct il faut donne moi des sous
mais jean-christophe vous aimeriez pas à
travailler dans le dimanche je ne dis
pas non non ce revers est chaude avec
ses bons oui papa plus non non non
développés de choc c'est parce que ça
nous a fait chaud c'est une cinquième
émission américaine qui a oui moi j'aime
beaucoup son frère jackie pas que les
ennuis qui écrit ce n'est pas le pire
j'ai prévenu les critiques toujours des
problèmes
pourquoi je n'ai pas quel montant et tu
as des êtres il ya plus de problème avec
l'administration antenne 2 d'un jour tu
m'as dit oulala je les problèmes un peu
minable
oui tant que quand il ya du papier bleu
dans son papier bleu c'est une bonne
semaine au lendemain de lorgnette sans
papier bleu c'est qu'elle est mais
comment des papiers plus c'est les gens
qui crient des lettres des citations et
pourquoi les menaces
vous avez vu dans les nouvelles
littéraires il y avait eu un premier sur
jacques martin j'ai vu ça je me sens pas
chez les gens on disait jacques martin
un plus fort que jean christophe averty
l'interrogation n'est pas vu ça les
regarde
marchant plus sur la même longueur
d'onde
bon eh bien écoutez je vous dire les
rapports mais comment survit cinq
minutes effet la petite farce qu'on
voulait vous faire parler
voilà mais non meilleurs que nous avons
obtenu des considérations très
importante jean louis borie sur
l'académie goncourt arriva brouillac
tous mes copains tu n'as jamais y en a
qui meurent cata pour le siège de finir
je voudrais bien alors
et bien donc vous avez donc assisté
d'une petite farce pas très méchant mais
ça va permettre aux téléspectateurs de
voir ce qui se passe sur le plateau d'
apostrophes dans les quelques minutes
qui précèdent les missions dans un bus à
ce détendue on peut parler les gens ont
dit des bêtises
voilà mais maintenant redevenant sérieux
et je vous annonce le 95e numéro d'
apostrophes farceur et pasticheur je
vous rappelle que nous sommes le 1er
avril
vous oui alors une autre farce notre
part sur un autre récepteur ou wade un
personnage enfin cali maroc à lima je ne
sais pas un petit oiseau
je vous présente mes invités